Justin well instrument is right outside
he does magic for humans on Netflix and
all of us being humans and over 50% of
our listener base being humans Justin
Willman is degeneration huh hello he's
the magician for you to see it what's
going on man how are you are you good
talking about humans I hear well yeah
and the magic that's for them I don't
like to rule out any audience for humans
it's all encompassing that's smart
how did you how did you end up being the
magician that gets the Netflix show
because Netflix they do a lot of comedy
yeah not a lot of magic not a lot of
magic right it was their first magic
show real magic show yeah because they
you know what they did do and I don't
know if this [ __ ] you up and you were
like we got to take this back from
magician huh is I watched on Netflix
they brought back all those you remember
from like the late 90s early 2000s the
master magician tells all tells all the
secrets they put all those on Netflix
and I rewatched all of them so I could
learn all this where they say do you
give away the trick yeah the other
magicians wanted to smash that guy so
absolutely I forgot now what's sad is
that if they if they're like oh if you
like magic for humans you'll probably
like you know knowing how everything
works so right refer you to this show I
did like two failed pilots for Comedy
Central who also does comedy Jen does
not do magic and continue to not do
magic they could they said no but it was
I kind of recut the the trailers from
that and pitch Netflix and they were
like do it yeah all right
we'll do it a guy with no masks doing
magic yeah we like that now when do you
tell everybody how it's done no I
actually do this on the road and we make
a living we're not gonna tell you you
use any cameras I have to ask that
because they said someone has said
Copperfield had used camera tricks for
like the Statue of Liberty or different
angles and then yeah and like Criss
Angel used to do like oh look Shaq is
floating across the neighborhood yeah
well I mean camera tricks it's like a
it's a subjective thing I I obviously
the show's edited should make it tight
in 22 minutes but everything you see is
what it would look like if you were
there just watching it and being amazed
so you know it's tighten to make me
funnier make maybe the
I understand eat it yeah yeah trust me
all right
so the cameras over shoot but no
sweetening no sweetening right you know
the camera tricks are more used for the
jokes than the magic trick exact I see
oh yeah the illusion of comedy is strong
with yet one exactly I saw the I saw the
one William the invisible one the
invisibility wanna convince people that
they're invisible which was very funny
Netflix must be so happy when like to
promote the show the thing goes viral
they love it cuz it's got like 5 million
views the trick is that you know you get
a flashmob it's really more of a prank
than a magic trick yeah but I added a
magic element I made I made one dude
actually vanish you know kind of like a
street version of the classic the eyes
the convinced sir uh-huh so the dude
takes the bait and it went great right
but now like a bunch of parents are
doing it to their kids and these kids
are yeah you don't need to do the
convincing if you're their parents the
person they love and trust more than
anyone the world and you act like
they're invisible you believe them right
like why would my parent ever lie to me
you get traumatized right yeah have you
watched any of the of the people trying
it at home so the trick is no that's
funny the trick is that like a guy is
you you got a flash mob right and I'm
Craigslist right yeah so they're all
they're only good looking at life flash
mob to Craigslist but they're all hired
people like they're all in on the gang
right you put a blanket over a guy's
head you pull him off and then everybody
acts like the guy's invisible well the
one guy you made disappear
you pull the blanket off and he's gone
so the other guy sees and then you do
the thing with the soda can where you
let him hold the soda can so the other
guy sees okay this guy really is
invisible but where they really get them
is you have the flash mob people take a
photo with the empty chair exactly ahead
of time I had it that was very smart and
then the same flash mob people come up
and take a photo with the guy and then
the guy sees the photo and he's not in
it and he starts to lose his [ __ ] right
my favorite thing is when I read
comments people are like hey where do I
get that app that makes the photos like
they're gone
so I should sell just a BS app yeah but
now like people are doing this to kids
at home and they're just doing that part
where they put the sheet over them and
they've already taken a photo but when
the photo
vo happens these kids who are like under
ten are losing their minds they go into
hysterics they're crying they're like
it's really it's scarring it's the it's
the ideal goal reaction to magic it's
just traumatizing a child yeah how many
hours have we all spent wondering what
how great would be just to be invisible
like your drawing I spent my entire
adolescence feeling invisible yes and
that's what leads to magic absolutely
now I know how that feels when I try to
sell tickets
yeah how great would it be if a guy just
immediately started like committing
crimes right is the magic trick you're
not actually we can see you yeah yeah
I'm really happy that I was not the
person who did a trick on how quick
would you've taken your dick out it
would have been literally as soon as I
saw the blanket come off the other guy
might zipper open I was like this is a
wonderful trick so did you realize that
this was gonna be your Invisible Man
trick was gonna be your like this is the
my free bird yeah exactly exactly well
what the day we shot it I knew cuz I
used to do this bit on stage in my live
show when I'm playing clubs that kind of
like get two dudes out of the audience
and I send one to the lobby because
we're gonna do a mind-reading thing and
which is all bs and then I tell the
audience the whole invisibility bit and
I knew people really dig it because the
audience just loves being in on this big
old prank and the the dude often does
believe he's invisible on stage even if
he's drunk and you know even if his
wife's in the audience his wife turns on
him and does this bit so I knew it would
take off but I just didn't know would be
a you know like a kid a kid thing what
do you own who ate your Halloween can
right right right what do you do they
don't believe it this guy be four times
on stage or doesn't work just give the
people like no not I try to pick like it
I try to pick a dude from the audience
that's kind of like the mindset of a
twelve-year-old as you can see is what
works out the worst part like because
even though like we all want to know how
it's done like it's like sometimes I
don't all right I know it's a trick but
I still like it like I don't want it
wrecked
I still enjoy not knowing how stuff is
done just to enjoy it for what
I always want to sell magic right I
always want to know and then once I do
know I'm like oh that was funner before
exactly because that's really not that
big of what you know you can never
unknow right right it's a problem I
think that's a it's a more refined
evolved mindset I think some people
the Dumber people are the more they're
like aw you you know if I don't know you
think I'm stupid no I think if you don't
know you realize that we need we we have
too much cynicism in the world little
wonders nice everyone Penn & Teller do a
nice balance of like showing you how
it's done sometimes yeah deconstructing
it but not [ __ ] it up for other
magicians they're really good and that
fool Penn & Teller thing is great where
they tell you we will blow the trick we
know how you if you don't believe that
they know how you did it they'll tell
you little hints yeah like they really
are delicate with how they will let
somebody down there once in a while they
just get fool that's a great show it's a
great show yeah yeah plus they're like
some tricks that once you learn the one
that trick is just it's used over and
over and over again like like the like
the one you did on Alan like the coconut
uh-huh falling out of the calendar yeah
like I wreck I don't know how that trick
is done but I recognize it in the sense
that if I knew how that was done yep
that's like half magicians acts it's
like two-dimensional three-dimensional
that's like a chapter in the book of
magic how do they do you probably won't
tell me but because this is another one
of those that like you see done in
various different ways but I saw I think
I was when we were in Hawaii there was
like a magic show that like it was
sleight of hand and it was close-up yeah
it was like in this tiny little
auditorium it did seated like 75 people
or something but you were like right on
top of the guy which is the best because
then he really has to be he has to be
good yeah but it was that thing where
like you had a dollar and you check the
serial number beforehand and then you
cut into an orange and the dollar is
inside the orange but there's no way
because you just cut into it how do you
get the dollar how does it how does he
do it it's all sleight of hand he's
holding the dollar
I mean he's holding this not in the
orange no no no I see it in the orange
he pulled it he pulled it out he didn't
get him is the master magician but he
witnessed it has a way of getting it
into his hand so it looks like he's
pulling it up but oh you mean so he's
pulling one out and then there's the
real dollar right here and he just yeah
don't worry they're amazingly quick like
somebody in Ocean's eleven I don't have
you ever seen that film you gotta have
one good slide
and guy oh that's one of the skill sets
in you know before you rob the casino
and then you need a fruit produce guy
salad you know
yeah I love the [ __ ] I love sleight
of hand stuff because you know they're
just moving their hands faster than you
can see it that because you know where
to look their hands right the [ __ ]
hands and is still at he still you can't
say it yeah I always the best I always
get annoyed when it's like the magic
trick is well we spent a million dollars
creating this set that does this and I'm
like what you didn't do any you just had
a bunch of money then right you know I
mean that's not Rube Goldberg device
exactly self you don't even need to be
here exactly that's not like a skill set
where it's like no I learned how to
shuffle cards like I saw we had a in
here I can't remember his name but a the
blind guy who's that yeah the greatest
Richard Turner yes yes fantastic and
he's unbelievable but that's just
because all he's blind and all he does
is just sit there all day shuffling
cards over and over and all that what is
he good sleight of hand guy or does he
just shuffle whoo no no no he's great at
card tricks how [ __ ] does he know what
the card is against see if that's part
of the magic I think he starts with the
deck I like fresh order and he did from
if it's if it starts that way he just
knows what he's doing he's not behind
everything
he's not blind that's what I do he's not
blind that's the trick I'm so hoping
that's the trap line that it's the
prestige yeah did at the end of it at
the end of his life he's just finally
gonna admit that he's not blind if you
would do that huh he's not blind cuz I
mean at one point like he seemed really
blind when he was in here oh yeah Pacino
in Scent of a Woman man there's well
he's a fan tab magicians often overcome
obstacles there's a magician from the
1700s Matthew bouffier born with no arms
no legs became the most famous magician
in Europe with high marks medical only
do it just goes to show you what a man
can accomplish when he can't masturbate
how did he all of his concentration when
my limbs disappeared what did he how did
he become a market but he was also 22
inches tall he was just they call him a
little man of Nuremberg and he would use
his mouth or his kind of shoulders my
god
nine children he had nine City real yeah
to me back then like the twins
the two Asian twin with the name sign
whatever than the two Siamese twins Chan
and something they were very very famous
not they were attached at the midsection
they both went on to have a bunch of
kids it's like how do you [ __ ] with
someone attached to you back in the old
days but they weren't pretty amazing
yeah the people that the people in the
circus would have kids yeah they are
Chang and Eng bunker yeah but they were
like carnies you know they were filthy
people yeah they were so attached to the
chest they're attached at the deck well
at what point did you realize you're
gonna be able to make a living as a
magician because especially I mean
you're doing stuff I feel like magicians
nowadays it's tough to make a living as
a traditional yeah you got any crafting
right you have to be creative which
often means kind of like you know doing
some gigs you're not proud of is that
right well I worked through high school
doing kids birthday parties bar mitzvahs
when you were a party seemed more fun
though because they believed everything
and they just did you Loudoun yeah but
also if you I mean if you screw up and
they you know they'll tell you they know
how it works they'll yell and scream so
it's a good on it won't let you down
they will let you know have you [ __ ]
up in front of kids party [ __ ] I think I
probably have I used to like yeah I used
to do a bit with a ride make a rabbit
appear and I kind of have this the cage
secretly in my table and I would load
the thing in the pot before so I load
this thing and then I'm like talking
getting ready to do the thing and that's
just see a bunny like hopping behind me
and the kids are like what you do yeah I
made them appear as my bunny it appeared
from its cage how did he do they get out
once in a while they get out of way yeah
so how many rabbits you gonna bring with
you yet I dare should have brought a
backup yeah yeah and I did but I used to
just after 9/11 I remember trying to
travel with them with a bunny
I'm giving the wrong impression about my
style of magic that's fine with a bunny
ended up but they don't let bunnies on
airplanes anymore why 9/11 she said why
rodents so they started enforcing this
law they think they're gonna chew
through the wires or something
I think the shoe behind the bunny or
something I don't know but they yeah
yeah shoe bomber originally tried to
sneak something in a rabbit and it will
rabbit's foot but bigger a bigger bomb
so how did they get look how do you get
your rabbit around I think now you just
in the crate under the under the plane
rabbits is so [ __ ] scared of
everything why don't we just use rabbits
that are [ __ ] horrified they're
adorable thank you
they're grateful for the work yeah I
just want some guy that made little
chicks appear under a cop yeah it was so
cute haven't got that one pet the little
chicks right I loved it I bet you did I
did was this it was the wrap party for
uh what was uh Moshe kasher show called
oh yeah thank you proud man yeah where's
the wrap party for probably hit a
magician who was awesome
yeah Johnny ace Palmer so you're talking
about is it where he makes the little
chicks I die with the chicks that's his
gimmick so you started doing stuff with
chicks would he be like I'd get yeah
it'd be like a comedian stealing in
other comics jokes probably probably the
little chicks appear under these cups I
got it and all you want to do is go pet
them now I got a very door and then they
probably grow I mean they don't fit in
the cups after a week what do you think
he does with those chicks that's what
worries me
I hope he sells little chicken wings
after don't cook my props a bag so when
you're in high school and you're doing
magic are you doing it like are you a
tuxedo magician uh you weren't saying I
was at first when I was like 13 I'd saw
a son Lance Burton in Vegas right George
Ellis he was great yeah and he would do
dub pseudonym you know I was a classy
count yeah so I kind of mimicked that
and then I ditched that and kind of went
more Matt King was one of my heroes
comedy magician in Vegas so that kind of
became the the path so no tux but this
goes I think that tux is what separates
it because when you're a kid middle
school high school and you're a magician
I think when just a normal person does a
magic trick you think it's cool like if
you just do like a simple little card
trick for somebody in life even in high
school it's like all cool you can do
cool [ __ ] but when you're like a tuxedo
magician you can be labeled what's known
as a nerd you know that's you or a
tuxedo to school right right did you
ever do any of those kids parties and
realize like oh this is the younger
sibling of like the girl in high school
and now she's looking at me like making
rabbits appear this is women love magic
well some women love magic but not like
delayed at this party I don't you know
what an older guy I don't know if he
even tried I just saw him packing his
[ __ ] up
um and I crying he was just crying he
was just weeping and I was trying to get
laid and I did not it was a what's the
term a giant swinging to miss you didn't
you didn't make it no I didn't know I'm
sorry to hear that
thank you but when you were in school
with like when you were first learning
you're a kid and you're doing this stuff
do people think it was cooler did people
think you were nerd I think people
thought was cool they did yeah people
thought it was cool um it was always
like hey show us a trick show me a trick
okay well yeah that's it magic boy sorry
a trick can't have any year energy today
I'll do something for you magic on the
radio whoo people like to hear the hosts
struck in wonderment literally like I
was like yeah well I have you know
Justin and I was watching the show we'll
talk to him and Jim was like I love
magic everyone Jim is also like I want
you to know it's gonna have to be a
really good trick yeah because Jim is a
he's a student of the dark arts yeah I
will all scream out how the tricks are
done that's right that's what I do and
he's got he's at a young age he made a
pact with the devil I did yes so he
knows yes he know he helps me how to
Devils got a good lawyer I guess yeah
all right so are we ready for a magic
trick shall we let's do it don't you get
nervous doing a magic trick Levi went in
someone says are Jim's him do a couple
of his jokes I'd be humiliated that's
that's I'll show you what's your name
did you see the show rub Mike Robbie
just yelling - Rob don't lie to try to
flatter him I saw the the one which one
did you talk about the whole show the
whole shot the whole show I've got a
little this is more of a little prize
than a magic trick but oh I think Jim
and Sam will enjoy this is Rob the
flashlight is good yeah that's exactly
so I've got six prizes Rob whichever
number you pick I'll give you that thing
right now so what do you want one two
three four five or six five do you want
to change your mind no five okay it's
like index cards or something and it's
like it's like a foam board it says the
number five on it yes I know you see
what just shows it a hug Oh can you have
it from the back of here Rob getting a
ha
can you put his face on the console and
hug him from the back okay he's getting
a hug that's nice okay everyone every
other every other number every other
that's an amazing trick every other car
the back of it said Anil do you want to
change your mind Rob do you want to
change your mind Rob you almost had to
have anal sex from Justin can you
believe that Rob is just bad that he
didn't pick one of the other taking
three five prizes remain that is a mate
that's the great trick it makes my wife
nervous this Ben yeah because I'm a man
of my word yeah you could go wrong into
the bargain you got it yeah don't do
that at college you know you might be a
get in trouble for harassment that's
that's true who's that guy tried to
apologize for doing a trick or something
on stage didn't the magician come sounds
right yeah yeah yeah every card said
anal except for one and Rob Rob picked
the wrong card obviously yes that's
great opener do you do colleges I used
to do a lot of colleges often how do you
prepare for the Obamas I did they have a
Halloween party every year you do the
anal hugged joke without Michelle that
was an administration too soon for that
one right I yeah I did it kind of there
Halloween party everyone so I was all
dressed up in costume except for Obama
who was like dressed as Obama whose wear
a fleece looking shell and the president
doesn't dress up I guess the president
doesn't look stupid probably you could
imagine the press would turn on him for
anything yeah I imagine the president
like JFK didn't wear a cowboy hat when
they handed it to him uh-huh like I'm
not wearing that he just wouldn't have
like you know Dukakis was ruined by that
photo and then [ __ ] so bad photo can
wreck you in the public's eye smart very
smart what did you what did what did
were the Obama's magic fans that they
were incredible they were good already
fantastic great audience were you
nervous did you [ __ ] up the most nervous
I've ever been in my life yeah did I
don't think I [ __ ] up now what point
do you don't like alright this is gonna
go well it's just another magic show
like I meaning like you do your first
trick and you're like okay it worked
pretty much yeah first thing you kind of
like okay you got you get that litmus
test you know okay that's it's a that's
the response that I normally get I think
this is on track you beat them
beforehand I did meet them beforehand
that pie take some of the nerves awake
you've already got that out of the way
definitely they like you and they read a
clue sets I did
set earlier in the afternoon that the
president was not in it was like kind of
a warm up the the beat crack exactly it
was the the the sit-ins the saying you
know the seat fillers and that I was
able to get the the nerves out what's in
an hour
was that 45 minutes that okay yeah now
now what's worse when you're doing a
magic show and you [ __ ] up a trick or
you like you know something falls out
your sleeve or whatever it is or when
the tricks are fine but the audience is
just like who cares you know what I mean
when you're just not getting a reaction
yeah that's those both suck I'd say when
you [ __ ] up a trick it's very hard to
recover from that because if you know if
you do a joke and just down fun times
messed up the delivery that bombed you
can just move on but when it's like when
when the trick is exposed it's like your
dick fell out like you can't you can't
talk your way out of that so what are
you doing that happens there's got to be
like some kind of a thing you have like
if I have jokes bombing I kind of know
how to address it or I are you you know
what to do to at least move along to the
next what do you do if a [ __ ] trick
just just the bed I try to create a
persona where half the things look like
just jokes that aren't supposed to be
tricks anyway
and I just try to pass it off as that's
how it was supposed to be well magician
wit my dick out magicians are smart
because like every magician has a bunch
of tricks where it's like it's the false
negative where like you screw up the
trick on purpose because the real trick
is coming yeah so I would imagine if you
screw it up a trick legitimate your
first attempt is to try to make it seem
like that's part of the act exactly
right exactly right right where you go
well but what about this over here
everybody look that way round try to
compose myself again where my chicks
yeah where are my chicks those save the
day and everyone likes animals they do
everyone likes to see an animal in a
trick just you everyone likes it
I mean I guess so [ __ ] girls went
crazy when they pull those little chicks
out they went nuts it'd they [ __ ]
melted who they like petting him yes
they did did you yes I did everyone
likes petting a small animal is that
right yes did you know that by the time
they were chickens they'd be brought to
a slaughterhouse while new chicks came
in to replace them no I was saying as I
petted them you're gonna die yeah
goodbye friend yeah enjoy this now this
is not how your human interaction will
always be how did you how do you
getting picked for the Obama gig you
know so I used to do a show every every
summer in st. Louis where I'm from and a
little girl who'd like I guess was like
five when she first saw me and she would
see me every year became like an intern
at the events committee at the White
House Wow
there you go Wow who knew and that's it
why yet planting seeds man that said
that's that thing of like just make sure
people like you you know I mean just you
know you're [ __ ] with be nice
exactly so when you walk in there okay
and you're gonna meet the president and
his wife where they do they take you
into rumors or a lot of people in there
how does it work yeah you've got a whole
line and a security is for a magician
getting into the White House was
horribly obnoxious oh my god II
literally just every single yeah and
yeah you're you know you're in this
photo line and they don't they don't pay
you to go to the White House obviously
cuz you can imagine the backlash Obama
spending money on a magician right so
you kind of just you're thrilled to be
there but it's all for the photo op so
right yeah they take care of you with
that you're just kind of gradually
approaching and and he was you know
shake his hand hey arms around you know
you have fun with them together got it
together yeah yeah when you when David
Blaine starts getting super famous for
doing like I mean his stuff like stop
being magic and was just stunts uh-huh
are you like what do I have to do like
what do I have to do now like when he's
holding his right he's just sitting on I
see that's cool and people are like yeah
that's that's that's what it looks like
or he's like you know he's doing agents
last special you figured out how to just
drag a a giant needle through his hand
and it's like no the trick is you just
have to know exactly where to put the
needle in your hand and you can puncture
your hand or you know I'm like I have a
run out of tricks like that right it's
kind of you know that's that there's
there's there's he's got a certain
insanity to him that is brilliant in
that no one really is the real deal like
that I mean I love it but do you not
worry as a magician like oh no if this
is where the trend goes I'm gonna have
to start doing stuff like that
I never really did worry about that I
feel like I feel like some people are
just a little creeped out by that you
know like they will people want it to be
a trick so I don't want to think that
he's really putting that thing Bruce and
I want there to be a trick right you
just do I could do that if I had a
higher tolerance for pain was he really
putting through his hand yeah yeah yeah
that's what he does
or
like like you know he does the thing
where he swallows a goldfish and then he
throws up the goldfish and it's because
he drinks a whole bunch of water he
fills up his stomach
the goldfish sits there and then he
actually just throws up the goldfish
it's it's not magic he's doing it how
did you break both your arms Connor you
started what they said the dexterity
would come back if you started doing
card tricks
yeah I broke my arms I was riding my
bike while wearing rollerblades like a
genius
fell off cause oh you really want to get
somewhere didn't you really what it how
old were you 12 and your parents weren't
like girls don't ride your bicycle with
your rollerblades I don't think they
ever thought they would have to say that
I think if it was implied but I didn't I
didn't get a curb or something you flew
off I was going downhill and it was some
friends and she like you know you know
when you brake with the front brake on a
bike like an idiot and you kind of flips
your front bag did that both of you
thought my thumbs
yeah it was in cast for six months when
you're 12 that's inconvenient time did
you not go to school didn't go to school
for a while so no homework like how did
you do it no no but I'm saying how did
you do that they did a chip pile up the
teach no homework for me I can't point
closer because I can't move my arm it's
not a bad question
I mean did you just have to tell them
the answers like what are they doing you
can't us who has no homework and two
shattered arm dad I think I think you
kind of verbally fill it out I seem to
recall my mom being my stenographer oh
and she would to do it and that's what
moms are for she didn't help me out with
everything but how do you wipe your ass
don't chat two broken arms what happens
well luckily you just hope you don't
have a diarrhea problem
you know day or something but humanity
shame but come on man two broken arms he
at 12 you know what your parents why is
mom either you have to start wiping my
ass or you have to install up a day
he's totally up to you toda watch it
someone I thought your ass did it no I
was able to wipe my it wipe and you kind
of can get it around okay I own ass what
do you do if you break both arms [ __ ] if
it's a nurse it's not bad yeah [ __ ]
fish around okay so so far Jim's like
wait a minute no homework and the nurse
gets to wipe your ass I'm on it break it
both your arms is cool but imagine
having your parents if you're really old
you do people will do it
to parents wiping your head swapnika
just in your in your mind like can you
imagine go into a 12 year olds house
he's got two broken arms and he's like
yeah but guess what
no homework and your friends are like
yeah B if two broken oh well I wasn't
saying no homework like it was cool I
was wondering how do you do it like what
just does it just add up or do you have
to just say your answers I don't know
why I was wondering that still run
discussion it was not a bad question you
have a great answer for mom no but the
doctor legit like recommended I learned
card tricks is physical therapy and
that's that's how you did that's
malpractice as advice but it worked for
me it did work yeah yeah do you think it
actually helped you or it just helped
you learn card tricks I think I think it
actually helped okay I mean it wasn't
serious enough that I needed you know
like a legit physical therapy it kind of
it what it helped is that it helped my
dad take magic seriously as opposed to
just being some passing fad right
because the doctor recommended he's like
alright so you ready do it let's do it
how long did it take you to get good at
it I'd say five years do you steal [ __ ]
from people like because I feel like if
I was so good at sleight of hand like
you're like you're very very good at
magic right I feel like if I had the
ability to take a guy's watch like you
know there's that guy Cameron Burt's
magician would my team and David blame
it's like taking George Bush's watch yes
off his wrist right I'm sure that you
can do that too I can do that and I
wouldn't I wouldn't intentionally steal
but there are times where I've like
pickpocketers stolen watch and just
forgotten to give it back you wouldn't
take somebody's messes stealing he
really took pushes Wireless right off
his wrist with the Secret Service right
there
it's amazing what these magicians can do
it's incredible we come back I want to
see that that's [ __ ] amazing if I if
I had the abilities that you have I'd be
stealing everyone's wallet everyone's
what everyone's wallets yeah that's
right I'd be getting five dollars here
Metro car Metro cards no hydrants you
can't use so you never thought to
yourself I could be a magician but also
have a life of crime of thievery yeah I
did I in college I think I did you know
shoplift some candy bars at the 7-eleven
I think pockets are amazing how but you
did more I'll bet it's just like as a
magician you have to have a certain
image but I've
you've stolen some things I would yeah
passing the bowl around there's a little
you know slide a hand with the nug or
something I don't know how could they
distract you there's a certain pressure
like they'll bump into one part of you
and pull it out like this and you're
also risking going to jail and getting
punched in the face like that's a real
[ __ ] a risk I don't know how they do
it but that's a they bump into you I
think I saw it on Ocean's eleven they
bump into you and they're like oh sorry
sorry sorry and as they're going like
sorry sorry they reach in in her pocket
take whatever's in your inside pocket
out bye
I feel like I'm unpick pocketable I'm so
nervous what are you talking about I
could I'm always aware that I touch my
wallet in the subway constantly you're
one of the easiest marks I could
possibly s you know I would never give
our stuff you're very easily
distractible I'll come on the train with
a chick just go with Jim you want to pet
this chick yeah but I would still feel
your hands fishing around by my [ __ ]
I don't love my ass doesn't go numb
women he keeps his wallet in his [ __ ]
get it out of there